le parfum de la Coupe de France flottait
dans l'atmosphère du stade et
m'hébergeal de Mantes-la-Ville les
joueurs locaux du FC Mantois 78 qui
évolue en R1 recevait le Paris 13
Atlético en club de National en première
période les Parisiens ouvrent le score
sur ce corner avant la 10e minute de jeu
1 à 0 ce sera le score à la pose on a
pris un but au bout de 6 minutes donc
c'était c'était difficile mais après on
a eu du répondant c'est en face c'était
une équipe de national qui joue trois
divisions au-dessus donc on n'a pas trop
à
avoir deux regrets au retour des
vestiaires les visiteurs font le break
suite à ce coup franc après cette
combinaison 2 à 0 quelques minutes plus
tard le FC Mantois récolte un carton
rouge et n'arrivera pas à revenir dans
le match pas de miracle fin de parcours
dans cette Coupe de France 2022-2023
pour le club ivinois scénario
catastrophe on prend le but au bout
d'une minute trente donc après c'est
difficile à 2-0 surtout qu'après on
prend un rouge donc il ne restez plus de
35 minutes à jouer à 10 donc après c'est
sûr que c'est toujours plus difficile
franchement la deuxième période on a été
plus tranchant en première période on a
été on regardait un peu le ballon on
sortait pas sur le joueur mais en disant
par là on a su se reprendre le FC
Montois va maintenant se focaliser sur
le championnat de régional une le club
ivinois est actuellement la 11e place du
classement avec un bilan de deux nuls et
une défaite en trois matchs